así es de muchísimo respeto la gente lo
que nos ha dicho es que ella hizo pues
tuvo un rol es un rol extraordinario
aquí en escocia de hecho ofrece el 70
por ciento de las personas así incluso
algunas no que no apoyan la monarquía
consideran en realidad pues que ella
hizo muy bueno durante todo el tiempo
que duró su reinado y sobre todos los
que fue una mujer que estuvo allí
siempre para el pueblo por eso había
algo que era muy duro para ellos y es
que esta mujer que los acompañó durante
70 años en los momentos más duros a
veces en momentos de tristeza del dolor
incluso después de muerte pues esta vez
no tienen a esa mamá para que los
acompañe en este momento sino que
simplemente pues tendrá que pasar la
página es un poco como una nueva época
una nueva era la que comienza a partir
de ahora así que muchísimo respeto si
por esta mujer de hecho como les decía
una de las invitadas a esta ceremonia es
la presidenta del parlamento que está
listo johnston y ella es del partido de
los verdes un partido que de hecho es
anti monarquía pero ella esta mañana
explicar una entrevista que tenía
muchísimo respeto por la reina de hecho
había visto el pasado mes de julio y
pues que era una mujer que sabía de
todos los temas con los que ella había
podido hablar era una mujer que estaba
muy enterada de lo que sucedía no
solamente en inglaterra sino también
aquí en escocia en realidad en todo el
reino que tenía muchísimo respeto por
esta mujer